and now the president of the University
Lisi Bollinger
it is my very very great pleasure to say
on behalf of the trustees and the
faculty of Columbia University
congratulations to all of the classes of
2009 this event this graduation ceremony
in this glorious space on this
magnificent day is both exhilarating and
humbling there is no other occasion I
can think of that has the greater has a
greater purity of happiness and goodwill
than this one the concentration of joy
and well-deserved satisfaction contained
by the walls of these buildings which
besit to speak an intellectual life is
as potent the force as exists in the
universe more happiness per square inch
that we are ever likely to see again
years of mental labor and toil have
brought you to this moment and marking
this intellectual milestone is our happy
and simple mission for the day and I am
honored to share this with you standing
on these steps I cannot help but recall
several other memorable and moving
moments this past year when students
faculty and staff came together here in
what has come to be regarded as
Colombia's town square on these steps
this past September 11th we stood
together in memory of those who lost
their lives eight years earlier and to
listen to presidential candidates John
McCain and Barack Obama
who had come to this campus to talk
about one of Colombia's defining values
service to our neighbors our nation and
the world then on these steps on january
twentieth we stood as one to witness the
inauguration of the first Columbia
Graduate and the first african-american
president of the United States
and on these steps and on these steps on
far too few balmy days this cold damp
spring you have set with friends and
classmates to share both some occasional
sunshine and some part of yourselves an
ageless form of connection that still
beats updating your Facebook page now on
these steps and all the way back butler
library we assemble once again for many
of you the last time to share the
exhilaration of today's commencement and
to feel humbled for today marks an
ending as well as a beginning you have
succeeded here but now you have new
goals to imagine and pursue it's
humbling to realize that the quest never
ends then there's the strange fact that
the more we learn the more we become
aware of how much we don't know
knowledge makes us feel ignorant and
that's humbling and finally this is a
time to take stock of the fact that you
did none of this alone you have
benefited from countless people as you
have set your aspirations struggled to
overcome life's disappointments and
celebrated your successes this is a good
moment then to welcome and specifically
to thank the parents the grandparents
the families and friends of the
graduates
on behalf of all of us at Columbia we
want to thank you for letting us have
the pleasure of teaching your children
to learn from them and to be inspired by
their hopes and dreams for the future we
share your pride in them we know that
many of you have made great sacrifices
to get to this day your love support and
faith in your graduates has given them
the courage to undertake the greatest
educational venture of their lives and
so before we go any further let's give
this opportunity to the graduates to
thank the people who truly made this day
possible your parents and Families
commencement is a time to imagine the
future and for those of us here today
who were older than you we know all too
well that the future seems to have its
own way of unfolding often very
differently than we anticipated but we
still should take advantage of this
grand occasion to step back and take a
large and long view of what service we
need to render to the world we now
inherit and will hand over to
generations who will follow you your
lives will stretch across this new
century today we can stand on your young
shoulders and in doing so perhaps peer
further into what lies ahead for me
living in one of the greatest
universities in the world so committed
understanding the world in all its
complexity and having spent my own life
thinking about the great principles of
freedom of speech and press I find
myself
I find myself increasingly concerned
about the need to secure and to realize
these freedoms on a global scale in the
increasingly interdependent emerging
global society that will in all
probability define the span of your
lives this is a matter of deep and
abiding importance to this class not
least because you have been here at a
pivotal moment in history you came in
texting and you're going out with the
Twitter and by the way there is an
impersonator of me on the twitter on and
regardless of whether you're a fan of
digital downloads or old-fashioned ink
on paper while you've been here while
you've been here you have seen the value
of dialogue and have accessed the timely
credible independently generated
information and ideas in august 2005
just as many of you were settling into
your first semester here hurricane
katrina was ravaging the city of new
orleans amid accusations of gross
government mismanagement and
misinformation your columbia years have
coincided with two brutal and still
unfinished wars in iraq and afghanistan
shaped by our own governments far too
extensive control over information you
will tell your children you will tell
your children about the unprecedented
economic crisis that erupted during your
time here a global event fueled by
inadequate disclosures and regulation
from the standpoint of our ability to
acquire a full understanding of things
that matter we clearly have a long way
to go before we can rest meanwhile you
have been witness to and strengthened by
participating in the process of vigorous
open debate on issues such as gay
marriage conflict in the Middle East and
climate change and you have played a
role in one of the most exciting
political campaigns in American history
a campaign waged like never before
through online media and social
networking you're going to hear from
them a lot actually
through it all you have lived in the
most privileged intellectual environment
on the planet and perhaps of all time
nothing compares to this to the freedoms
that you have felt and possibly taken
for granted the freedom to consider
every idea and to hear every speaker
imaginable and I mean every speaker as a
society we have long depended on two
major institutions our universities and
the press to be champion score to be
champions for and practitioners of the
principle of freedom of expression each
in its own way serves the public good
each offers its own kind of syllabus for
good citizenship and each is emblematic
of our larger responsibility to answer
bad ideas with better ideas not to hide
or be silent as a result you have had
that all too rare human experience of
thinking listening and speaking without
fear or threat of the sensors lash
America is radical among nations in this
tradition the most committed to free
speech Free Press of any country ever in
the stirring language of the Supreme
Court's famous 1964 decision New York
Times versus Sullivan we have put our
faith we have put our faith in a system
that is quote uninhibited robust and
wide open but it was not always so in
our country indeed it has been less so
for been less been so for less than a
century around the time of World War one
Congress could and hid make it a crime
to speak or publish anything that was
quote disloyal or scurrilous or could
cause contempt or scorn for the United
States the Constitution
flag or the military and on this campus
president nicolas marie butler
comfortably informed the Columbia
community that all vocal opposition to
the war would be grounds for dismissal
our judiciary at first found no conflict
between these laws and the First
Amendment but then over the course of
the next several decades it cleared away
the brush and the tangled vines of
censorship to give us the Vista of
freedom we have today our government
acted affirmative vividly in many ways
to do the same protection of state
secrets laws against speech beam
dangerous and offensive and laws
favoring reputation over free expression
all had to give way to a freer and more
open society this served a country that
was remaking itself we move from a
collection of individual states with
local jurisdiction to deal with local
problems to a national society able and
compelled to face up to international to
increasingly national problems as a
society we became more inclusive and
pluralistic making dialogue and even
greater necessity and our means of
communication expanded and we had the
good sense to know that we had to create
and fortify a national public forum
protected against the chilling effects
of local laws or censorship and
collectively we bet our future on a
simple proposition that people behave
better when they know more many many
people and many institutions over the
last century made it possible for you
and for us together to experience the
unfettered freedom of thought speech and
publication during your years here at
Columbia the question now before us is
both simple and profound namely how do
we do this on a global scale for an
emerging global society in this new
century to create a global public forum
that is uninhibited robust and wide open
and this task falls squarely on your
generation and since Columbia aims to
exemplify these values it falls squarely
on you this idea of a global public
forum arises out of the extraordinary
integration of the world that has been
accelerating during the years that
you've been here what we now call
globalization is mostly a matter of
increased trade in goods and services
through the opening of markets around
the world it is also through increased
contact through travel
internationalization of education and
new technologies like the Internet
and it is also a matter of the rise of
common global problems a degradation of
the environment and Wars and disease for
both good and ill globalization is the
defining phenomenon of the era and it
promises to be so even more in the
future meanwhile we do not have the
public institutions to make this global
integration work very well as we have
discovered with the recent global
financial crisis but an even more
fundamental fact is that we do not have
the information an exchange of ideas we
need to build the public institutions
and to devise the policies to make this
work what's more the very same
technology the internet that is making
global communications so pervasive is
simultaneously undermining the financial
model of the traditional press as we've
known it ironically and unfortunately at
the very moment when we want and need
more serious study of and reporting on
global issues we are getting less and
less of it the press are closing foreign
bureaus and decreasing coverage of
international news this is and also
cutting jobs
this is in addition to the observable
and regrettable regression in some of
the media into triviality popular
obsessions and intolerant and shallow
opinion mongery no one should take this
development lightly as walter Lippmann
wrote about the shortcomings of the
press in its coverage of the First World
War at crisis in journalism is a crisis
in democracy and no one no one should
assume that the institution's committed
to a professional culture of journalism
or scholarship can be replaced by
thousands of individual journalists just
as you cannot replace our great
universities with multiple individual
websites each offering specialized
knowledge in an atomized way next week
under the dome behind me we will give a
Pulitzer Prize for a deeply researched
newspaper report on how the Pentagon
successfully pitched it's a rock spin
too many of the former generals who
often appear as military experts in the
news it is unlikely that the lone
blogger could have had the wherewithal
to get and publish that story it is also
a fact that we can no longer expect the
free market to produce institutions that
actually play a quasi public role as
universities do or the press as the
fourth branch of government eventually
there will have to be new sources of
funding for the press other than the
private market for now oddly a
significant part of our world news comes
through the BBC and therefore courtesy
of the British citizens meanwhile other
government supported broadcasters from
China's CCTV to Al Jazeera English are
developing their own global presence we
have yet to realize that we will need to
compete for ideas in the global
marketplace of ideas we must also face
the face the harsh reality that much of
the rest of the world
does not take the same view of freedom
of speech and press that we now do many
countries forbid discussion about topics
deemed too sensitive or dangerous media
are strictly controlled by the state
with no allowance for private or
independent press transmitters block
signals coming from other countries and
internet portals are configured to
reject messages coming into or leaving
their country reporters are denied
access the newsworthy events or people
they're put in jail on trumped-up
charges or they are subjected to
unofficial violence tacit ly encouraged
or condoned by hostile governments but
the state of the sense of censorship in
the world today is in many ways not
unlike it was here in this country just
a century ago and it changed through the
dedication of many and the time of a few
generations what can be done about this
now there are many things actually far
too many for this address but i would
suggest just a few the first thing by
far the most important is that we need
to begin to see this as a goal nothing
ever really begins to change until
people start to think differently until
people embrace a new paradigm there have
always been and there are today many
people concerned about promoting human
rights including freedom of speech and
press around the world for these efforts
we are thankful but giving the growing
in their dependence and integration of
the world through globalization this is
no longer just a matter of human rights
that a very practical need for
information and ideas by which to
develop the institutions and policies to
make the world a better place the
society the message we must convey to
other countries is we cannot have an
economic relationship unless we also
have an openness to information and
ideas that is ultimately the foundation
of a true relationship and given that we
now live in the world in which
censorship in one country can lead to
inhibiting speech everywhere just as the
Court recognized in this country in
Sullivan we can no longer afford to view
local censorship as having purely local
consequences we must see the foreign
presses are pressed to for it is from
them that much of our information will
ultimately derive when journalists when
journalists and scholars languish in
prison when websites are banned in
signals blocked the rights of all of us
are now abridged finally we need to make
ourselves an even better example for the
world President Franklin Roosevelt said
some years after he left this university
without quite making it to where you are
today if the fires of freedom and civil
liberties burn low and other lands he
said they must be made brighter in our
own if other if in other lands press and
books and literature of all kinds are
censored we must redouble our own
efforts here to keep them free if in
other lands the eternal truths of the
past are threatened by intolerance we
must provide a safe place for their
perpetuation this is why today we need
to ensure that the press has full and
unfettered access to war zones to report
on where we are sending our young men
and women to fight not not embedded but
present as of right we need to provide
more funding for our system of public
broadcasting and entrusted with the
mission of reporting to and reporting
from the global arena especially where
the news media can no longer afford to
go we need to become more committed as a
nation to the development of
international law governing these
matters and we need to integrate more
than we do now in every field of study
in the universities and in every center
of policymaking a sense of how vital it
is to everything we want to do that
there be freedom of thought speech and
press that we have come to enjoy and
hopefully not taken for granted here at
Columbia
as our Attorney General of the United
States told those of you at the college
yesterday this graduation this
graduation may seem a culmination but it
is just the beginning of new
responsibilities of citizenship just
when you thought you were done with your
finals and papers here is a new and even
more challenging task living a life and
helping to build a world in which ideas
matter knowledge can be pursued freely
dissent can be heard and objective news
can be gathered and published that is a
worthy assignment for all of you and I'm
proud to add you are worthy of it my
greatest hope for all of you is that you
will find some such mission to which you
can dedicate your amazing talents and
good will and in doing so fulfill the
deeper ambition and purpose of the
knowledge and understanding we cherish
here and that exists to a degree
unparalleled in the world today on
behalf of all of us at Columbia we
congratulate you on this magnificent
milestone in your lives send you forth
with optimism that the good you can now
accomplished and look forward to your
saying in the future and it was on these
steps on May the 20th 2009 that I
received my degree from Columbia
congratulations